this is a production of Cornell
University okay so thank you it's really
nice honor to be back here especially
nice honor to be invited by the graduate
students that's so it was almost just
shy of eight years ago had my defense
right in this room so for all your grad
students in just a few years from now
you could have a bunch of children
running around at home and a bunch of
grad students running around the lab you
could be back here and so also I need to
dedicate this to like Rebecca and Edie
for the inspiration to work on high
throughput phenotyping we had this great
idea to work on the maze named
populations for disease resistance right
so I literally calculated up I literally
spent like one and a half months of my
life looking at maze lesions and
recording percentage disease leaf area
for thousands of plots over and over and
over again so there's a lot of
inspiration to do something more
efficiently than walking around Thanks
[Music]
okay so I always put everything in the
context of where we need to be in the
next couple of decades so he projected
60% increase in demand for wheat if we
leave everything with climate change
hotter climates you'll push that down
20% so we need about a 2% gain per year
and current currently wheats we does
that most major crops are about a 1%
gain per year so in the
context to the breeding cycle bingo you
know this thing is stuck at the top okay
whatever so in the context of breeding
cycle we're trying to make this cycle go
faster more efficient so we're making
crosses you know early stages you're
evaluating for diseases later stages
your value for yield and then really
late on the quality you pick the best
performing stuff and then you advance to
the next cycle so we really work in this
this mindset this mantra of if we can
make the breeding cycle go bigger and
faster then we can lead to more more
rapid improve riding so that's why we
work a lot of genomic selection we work
a lot on high throughput phenotyping and
so in this context the genetic gain over
time is a function of a selection
intensity so that you know we need
bigger populations
it's a diminishing returns but that's a
lot of focus on the high-throughput
phenotyping and the genomic selection
can help with with bigger populations
the selection accuracy this is some high
throughput phenotyping we can make more
accurate measurements than you can do by
hand the genetic variance we work a lot
on genetic diversity won't really touch
on that and then the years per cycle
that's also like a one of the components
of working on genomic selection so this
is kind of like putting all their things
together I'm just gonna really focus on
some of the things the fun the fun new
things that we've been doing with
genomic selection recently and so we
really have to define like what is
high-throughput phenotyping okay so
here's how we define high-throughput
it's like gonna be mostly or fully
automated data collection so currently
we're almost there right you like spend
like 15 minutes like collecting data and
then like 15 months like analyzing it so
it's not really high throughput yet in
that sense but we're almost there we
really define it as we have to be able
to do tens of thousands of plots so we
look at the actual breeding programs
they're operating in the thousands and
tens of thousands so if it's not
scalable to that then it's not really
scalable we got to do this in the
like I said it gotta be automated data
processing and data collection and then
I always note that like high-resolution
isn't really high throughput so if
there's one thing I learned at Cornell
it's like the power of big populations
so you don't have to measure things real
accurately you just got to measure them
on a huge population okay so so really
like how do we define what is HTTP it
says up there so one thing is the
breeder's the benchmark see this is dr.
Ravi Singh
he runs the Simic week program he can go
through in an afternoon 4,000 small
plots make really accurate selections
for height for disease for maturity and
so that's your benchmark right right
there okay so this is he says HDPE is is
high throughput painting right so you go
through and paint the ones that are good
and that's what gets selected right so
that's your benchmark right there the
other one is that breeders are
notoriously good is the combination here
at phenotyping meaning like just like
Robbie does he makes really nice
accurate selections for height but
nobody records the data so the point is
that if we're going to build prediction
models you actually have to have like
data numbers to go in to the models and
not just like breeders selecting it was
kept or not okay and then the last one
is like I said the power a big
population so we need to be able to like
apply these systems on populations that
are literally in the tens of thousands
so the semi program for example there's
50,000 new inbred lines generated every
year that go into a field block of some
sort
so in connecting the genotype to the
phenotype we do a lot of this we like
observe a phenotype quantitative
genetics we try and find some
correlation back to the genotype and
then we try and work out the biology of
how that those genes actually turn into
the phenotype we observe I mean of
breeding what we really want to do is
use the genotype to predict the
phenotypes into the next cyclist section
so in the scope of high-throughput
phenotyping what we're really talking
about is some phenotype that predicts
some other phenotype that's more
difficult to measure okay so one example
that you know that I'd like to show is
that canopy temperature is really easy
to measure that under under heat or
drought stress conditions that has a
really strong negative correlation with
you okay so this is just one example of
what we're thinking about in the high
throughput you know so a lot of what we
do in the high throughput phenotyping is
like direct sensor measurements of
something like a vegetation index and so
what you have here is like looking at
the ratio of the green to red to
near-infrared reflectance from that leaf
is a really nice assessment of the
overall health status of that plant
right nitrogen status any disease type
of problems and so we we become that
we've been working on this for several
years this is becoming really routine
especially with the UAVs to measure
literally like this last year we were
able to cover the 50,000 unique
individual plots at multiple time points
on the breeding program so this is
becoming really routine we've done this
with the ground vehicles so I'll just
highlight this here you know we started
out with this ground vehicle it's got
precision GPS on each side here a number
of sensors you we've been working on
these type of platforms for several
years you can drive through the field
like this those sensors are continually
collecting data we can use the GPS to
assign those back to individual plots
and so what that looks like then is you
can traverse back and forth in the field
each one of those being a single data
point you can take those data points we
we have different ways to survey out the
plot coordinate boundaries and then
based on that intersection of the plots
and the data points you can assign those
to individual plots in the field so this
has become over the last couple years
like sort of routine it's becoming very
routine we're also doing it with the
UAVs and so here's an example flying
some of these in India and nice thing
about the UAVs is being able to deploy
them all over the world so we can pack
them up in a suitcase you put these on
you know the field trials and in Mexico
and India all across we can haul them
all across Kansas and so here's like a
false color image of what that looks
like with the near-infrared band and so
from this you can very easily crop out
individual plots get an assessment of
NDVI and then what we've been doing is
incorporating those into prediction
models and so here's just an example the
grad students you can get these papers
and then go read them okay and then
there'll be a quiz after the class and
so with that right we can take these we
can incorporate them into combined
models that have genomic selection
combined with the high throughput
phenotyping data as like two levels of
information onto those onto those small
yield plots and then predicting like
yield as if it was a replicated field
trial but so that's really the that's
really the scope if we were using these
as like secondary correlated traits to
yield we're becoming very high
throughput and efficient in measuring
them across huge number of plots and so
now it's just a matter of optimizing
your prediction models so that's really
where we're at real brief overview of
where we're at with high-throughput
phenotyping for simple things like
vegetation index and so I didn't want to
just highlight that and use that kind of
as the background context of where we're
at for that so this is like that's the
last example like it's the real sample
of directly measuring something like
plant
greenness okay and then using that to
improve and we can we can drastically
improve the prediction models with that
level arm information this is an idea of
like phenotyping from images just
phenotyping flour color okay so that's
basically what we've been doing so this
is just really simple here right if you
take this picture and you apply a red
filter you can see that there's a lot of
red pixels here and no red pixels here
so we can very easily directly quantify
from the sensor measurements directly
from the sensor measurements we can
quantify what's the redness of that
flower okay so that gets us to traits
like you know how green is the plant but
we really want to get to more what I
like complex traits not in genetic
architecture but just in like the actual
physical architecture of those traits so
if you wanted to phenotype actually for
flower tight okay what this would look
like is you actually have some really
complicated function on here that the
you can look at this and say you know
this is a lily this is a petunia but
with that you're taking a lot of
background knowledge of like what the
shape of the flower looks like what
different colors those flowers come in
you know you know the one time your
significant other gave you some flowers
and they were petunias or lilies or your
favorite whatever it's this some really
complicated function to say like what
type of flower this is takes into
account the shape and everything so this
is this is where we get into like this
deep learning of wanting to be able to
apply this directly on images to score
complex traits and heat so this is like
the this is the real simple background
and here again we got like fabulous
computer science collaborators so I'll
give you my cursory overview and I'm not
reassure anybody really understands how
these work anyway so we'll just tell you
what we know about so these are
convolutional neural networks you start
with some two-dimensional representation
so this has to be like an image that
actually has like some spatial
representation of something and then
they're put through these convolutions
until you actually get linear mapping of
pixels into some function okay so if the
relationship we want is sufficiently
complicating meaning it's like some
plant morphology there's not really a
linear function that map's the input
data this this image into like an output
data that we want to put them in like
two classes okay so we can use these
deep learning it goes through these
complicated functions sequence simpler
functions that did the network learns
all at once so these are the
convolutional layers it takes it to be
convolutions over the map of input
values okay but the important part is
that some notion of spatial structure so
just like we look at it image has some
spatial structure okay so what do we
need so they real the real catch for
doing any of these deep learning
projects you have to have it's huge data
set before you can even start right so
this is like the catch-22 you don't know
if it's going to work until like you've
after you've done the entire experiment
right okay so you know you said we've
got data sets now that are actually
hundreds of thousands of images showing
this next slide or coming up it like on
that same phenotype where we actually
mounted multiple cameras and you can
drive through the field and take images
of the field so we did this over two
years 2016-2017 we have the same GPS so
we can we can assign those images to
individual field plots so we know every
field plot that each image was taken
from and then we can go out and score
for traits of interest right and then
assign those scores to the images that
were taken on that day from that plot
okay so this way we call them breeder
train data sets okay and then we can use
like some way to classification we can
classify them as percentages or we can
classify the images into some categories
is how this ways work and then we
penalize them by how far the way the
labels are like the labels that we gave
them to that the network gave them to
the to the ground truth right meaning
like the labels that we visually scored
the field plots
ok so that's the idea so so the real
catch it likes if you didn't catch that
the real catch here is that before you
know if this experiments going to work
you've actually invested like multiple
years of graduate students and postdocs
and and just to get the data set to see
if if you can train these neural
networks ok
so here's some of our field trials that
we've been doing this these are just one
of our research farms close to Kansas
State we did this in two years
most of our imaging these are winter
weeds so we plant them in October we
harvest them in June you know we we
image them through heading development
and through grain filling so that's an
April in May we have about two months
there way we do phenotyping and then the
germ plasm we did this on we had an
association panel this is 300 some lines
this is just winter wheat varieties
these are well-adapted these are all
elite type materials we don't have any
wild looking material in any of these
things and so these are winter wheat
varieties important to know and about 5%
of these were honest types so if you're
not familiar with wheat morphology you
can have on which are the little spikes
that come out of look we eat or you can
have on list which is like a naked type
type we head and then we had a
recombinant in Red Line population
Lincoln fivefold these are two varieties
so this is a pretty elite well adapt in
instead of germ plasm okay so here's
what our phenotype er looks like from an
aerial picture we've got like a little
canopy over there to make a little bit
of shading it makes the imaging a little
more uniform same thing you can see the
GPS units on top of that thing so each
image has a Geo position within within a
plot and then we have a some camera
setup where we have different cameras
just passing about less than half a
meter over the field plot and then
taking taking a really proximal image of
those fuel plots and so this is this is
kind of what that data collection looks
like and and not to underestimate you
know the amount of time and complexity
that went into like just getting the
datasets
so here's
like I said complex trait in who eat
it's not actually complex because it's
like a single gene controlled trait but
it's complex in the sense of like the
morphology okay so here's a picture of
some onlus types you see that there's no
beards on here and you see these long
beards coming out of the wheat head here
right so we have a few thousand pictures
that are on this and you know more that
are on here so this is the kind of this
is what the training data set looks like
you know we have thousands and thousands
of pictures that look like these two
sets here so we make this thing we call
it wheat net
I guess now so this is for scoring on so
we started out with this is a really
simple trait in the sense of it's just
got two classes and we can say yes or no
it's on or on this okay so we have about
700 plots this was two replications of
those 300 entries 29 of those are on
this okay so we must had one plot die
out it should've been 30 but so then we
separate these into a training and a
validation in the testing set remember
we did this across two years so we
trained it on one year and then we
validated a totally separate field
experiment from the other year so we
trained it so what we do is we pick out
several thousand images that are on
several thousand equal number of images
that are on this and then you train
these accordingly so then you validate
them so the important part is you train
it you tune them you tune the model to
optimize on the validation set and then
to be fair you have to do the testing on
a totally independent data set that
didn't go into any way into your model
building okay so this is what these guys
are computer science guys call these a
confusion matrix I don't really know why
but anyway this is the this is basically
the proportion you know here in it's
like a heat map here in in the white is
like is
is one to one so that the here's the
observed and here's the predicted right
so we hit like extremely high accuracy
99 plus percent accuracy on the training
set the validation set and the testing
set okay so what that looked like then
in in the image numbers there is is is
is is because these images can only be
fed into the network in small 250 by 250
sized images you can't take like an 18
megapixel image just computationally so
it's 250 by 250 so we actually have 10
image crops that come out of each image
and so that's the accuracy on those
image that they cropped out images and
then when we take a consensus from all
of the crops that come up from a single
image then we actually hit up to 100%
accuracy and then remember also that we
have multiple images from each plot and
so on a plot level base this weekend we
can hit 100% accuracy for scoring on vs.
on us okay so like that's pretty awesome
but you know you could walk through the
field in 30 minutes and score this also
so so we spent three years building a
phenotype err and you know full-time
postdoc and a computer graduate student
and you know several million CPU hours
but we can score on vs. on this ok so
now let's go to something a little more
interesting a little more complex this
is growth stages and wheat that's you
have to trust me that's what it says up
there and so if you look at wheat
development here you go through these
stages where we're in tillering stage
here then you're in stem elongation here
these nodes are coming out here and then
this is the important stage right here
where the head is coming out of the boot
so you know in a wheat grass the head
emerges out of the boot from that from
that flag leaf and this is real critical
stage obviously right that's when that's
when flowering is happening that
determines the overall morphology the
the timing of that flowering so and then
this is the critical grain filling
period so these are traditionally scored
as when 50% of the tillers have headed
on the boot so
you know like so visually this is really
easy to score you just look at the plot
you take a mental assessment of how many
tillers are out there and then you take
a mental assessment of how many of those
are 50% out okay but actually like when
you think about what actually just
happened in a split second in your own
neural network that's like actually
extremely complicated because you had to
take some visual assessment not just of
like how many are out but of like the
total density of those also okay
obviously it's a really important
physiological trait so like for example
in Kansas you can't be too early or
you'll get winter kill and you don't
want to be too late because then you'll
be into the heat stress of the hot
summers okay so this is really critical
breeder selection and so why was this
something we want to go after for http/1
is like a time series measurement so
it's recorded as a date so you actually
have to go out multiple time points
during the season to accurately measure
this right so it requires going through
all the plots each day or at least every
other day something like that
okay so here's what here's what some of
our image sets look like so we actually
do this now in time series okay so if
you take a plot early on it'll be all
leafy like this you don't see any heads
out you see one here just starting to
come out of the boot right so this might
be like you know somewhere between 1 to
5 percent headed right and here's
another one that's almost completely
headed out so it's a little dark to see
maybe from the back but you can see that
all the heads are out here now you might
have one or two real late ones this is
about 90% headed out here so what we do
now is we go through the field each day
we take a visual score or we run the
phenotype at the same time and then we
can we can take 10,000 images in a day
and by going through the field once we
can assign a value to every one of those
10,000 images and then we do that at
multiple time points through the season
so then you get an eye photos library
that looks something like this where you
you know you filled up your library with
hundred thousand pictures and every one
of them's like 10% headed or 90% headed
or 60% something like this
and so we have a huge training data set
now where we have all of these images
and they're tagged is like a breeder
trained type of score
so this is training wheat net for
heading here
I saw our training sets so here's where
we go back and we have two different
populations so we have one populations
diversity panel it's got a much bigger
morphology and then we applied this to
the buy print of population it's much
more narrow in its morphology okay so
the training set here we had this Lake
at Fuller by parental population in 2016
we had two years of the Association
panel and then we balance this out with
about two thousand images per maturity
level so so in ten ten percent
increments from 0 to 100 and so that was
a total around 20 thousand training
images and two hundred thousand patches
from those images so each one of those
patches actually counts as like an
individual training data point okay it's
in the validation set was the same thing
a hundred pots from this diversity panel
and this is the part that I don't really
know but if you're deep into neural
networks then then here's all the gory
details on this so you have to because
because of memory memory limitations you
have to feed these inner and small
batches so you can't actually you can't
actually put like 200,000 images and at
the same time and then we didn't have to
tune the parameters for how how fast the
is the learning rate and then how many
epics it's trained and then the total
number of training there so this was all
optimized and it turns out interesting
that the really crazy part to me is that
these networks are pre-trained unlike
just random images from the internet and
then we just train the last few layers
on the wheat data and then interestingly
like these networks that we train for
like the on versus on this versus the
percentage heading they it was like only
like the last one or two layers that
were trained differently okay
so what this looked like then in the
field is that if we go out over time
series so say right here we have plot
number one plot number two down to plot
number in if we go through the field and
we image those day by day and we also
take a visual score then we have a time
series imaging where we can assign an
image value and a percentage scoring to
that right so we can train the neural
network on these and then to do this at
high throughput we can just go measure
new plots and just have the images and
then using the neural network we can
actually assign the percentages to each
day right and then we just need to find
the intersection of when it goes above
50% and that would be the classical
measure okay so this is what it looks
like then so we do a time series imaging
and then we fit this percent heading
model here where we fit a logistic
regression onto those time series
measurements and so this is what some
real data looks like these are actually
visual scores and then I'll show you the
neural network scores in a minute here
so this would be a field plot this is
our plot identify our plot number two
zero zero one four where it was scored
on on day one 10 a zero the next time
point it would have been scored at 20 40
50 80 and then the rest of the time
points were scored at one honey so we
fit this logistic regression on here
this is just a classical resistant
logistic regression equation we take and
we fix Phi one here at 100% so that you
know all the wheat plots have to end up
at 100% headed out we actually put some
dummy variables at 0 and 100 which
passed our measurement day is just to
help fit the regression and then Phi 2
and Phi 3 here are actually the slope
and and then the intercept you know way
down here this the slope of that of that
curve here so we fixed by 1 by 100 we
find then we just simply find the date
at with which that which that logistic
regression intersects the 50%
right so we find 50% here we find that
date and then you know this one is
around J 1:18 we we assign that as the
heading date the cool thing here that
I'll come back to is that because we
have the slope of how quickly it goes
from 0 to 100 we can actually measure
the rate of heading K and so this would
be a really interesting trait that you
might think about you know in some cases
you weren't really rapid heading so that
everything uniformly heads at the same
time if you're in like a risky
environment where you might like get
late freeze or early early stress you
might want to stretch out a heading date
so this is a cool new breeding target
that we've been thinking about now that
you can actually like measure and then
presumably breed for the rate of heading
and so what we do then is we is we do
that exact same thing with a neural
network and so remember now the visual
scores are we go out here and we take
visual measurements the neural network
here is we actually image the plots we
train the neural networking we assign a
value for the image on each one of those
days so the purple dots here are scores
from the neural network based on imaging
and then we fit that same logistic
regression we find from the neural
network scores right based on that
logistic regression the heading date and
and then we can basically
fully-automated measure the progression
of heading and then find the date in
which it hits that classical measure of
50% heading so this is this is overall
how we do it right this is the example
of that same plot of course I show you
the best example where they like match
up perfectly right so yeah some of them
were really good here's another great
example where we hit you know basically
hit it right on the same day some of
them are not so good you know you have
some overestimation in the neural
network here from what the visual scores
were at and so that slope kind of gets
panned out and then you're then you miss
it by about a day
so basically now what we've done is
we've high throughput measured through
all of those plots we have a time series
measurement about 10 10 or 11 time
points where we've imaged dozens of
images for each plot and then we just
apply it individually this this
regression across all of those plots so
that's what this looks like then here so
this would be the on this axis here is
all of the time points that we took
visual measurements you can see that
those are nicely spaced out on Monday
Wednesday and Friday across the growing
season okay and so here's what we took
visual visual measurements and then this
would be that 50% estimate from the
visual measurements on this axis here is
that for each individual plot we fit
that logistic regression based on the
neural network scores and and then
intersected that and got the same
heading date for that and you can see
here these are the time points you tried
to do this every every other day so this
you know this big gap here it's like one
of the caveats of when it starts raining
in the field
you can't like drive your tractor
through it anymore so we had it we had a
pretty big gap in here where we weren't
able to image the field and so overall
though man we we had a big range and
heading in this particular population
but we had a really strong correlation
you can see that here there's a nice
one-to-one trend the the red line is the
fit and then the black line is the
one-to-one line on there and so we had a
really strong correlation I'm a mean
absolute error of less than one day and
a root mean square error of just a day
and a quarter so overall I think we get
you know I think we're hitting within
the tolerance of what you can actually
visually score also we did have you can
see kind of here we have a little bias
right in this region I think I'm not
real sure but my my working hypothesis
is that that's because we had good
imaging here and then we have this kind
of gap in our imaging time points and so
I think those curves got pushed up a
little high and so we early we estimated
the heading dates in this range a little
a little earlier than they should have
now but overall we can for compared to
the visual
with the neural network we can get 57%
of the plots within one day of the
visual estimate and we can get 88% of
those within within two days of what
they were visually scored so here's the
distribution of those of the overall
heading dates this is the day of the
year where we estimated the heading date
and this is the frequency for that
population here's the Lincoln and fuller
the parents of that of that by parental
population and the difference between
the visual and the neural network the
visual here is in the dark and then the
field the field background here and so
you can see for the parents we were
really accurate on those you can see
that little shift in the distribution
here between where we are in this you
know in this one 15 day range we were
about a day or two early on those but
overall we can match the distribution we
can get a really accurate assessment
over there so if you're an astute
graduate student now you're saying oh
there's something really funky with this
distribution that that doesn't look like
a normal distribution okay we'll come
back to that that's that's good okay so
the other thing you can't see up here
but this says 5/3 up there and so this
is actually the slope of of those curves
on there and so here's where I think we
you know we had some some a little bit
of bias with the neural network and the
imaging set is where in this
distribution here we're measuring the
slope of heading you know the rate of
heading using the neural network versus
the rate of heading for for the visual
scores and overall the you know the the
slope of the curve estimated for the
neural networks were steeper than for
the visual scores and this this is in my
mind I think this is due to just getting
uniform timing of the imaging data sets
okay overall I should say though to the
heritability on the actual measurement
of the heading day abroad since
heritability was around 0.92 for the
actual heading date and then
surprisingly we had we had good
heritability for both the visual and the
neural network slope around 0.5 0.45 so
I was surprised that we actually had
heritable measures of of the rate of
heading based on this approach so
overall now we can like start to look at
this in depth so here's just an example
this is comparing the 5 3 so remember
this is the slope this is the rate of
heading compared to the heading date so
you might say oh you know the the rate
of heading is just determined by when
you're actually heading but what we can
see here is that there's a slight
negative correlation but it's actually
really weak so interestingly you can
know you can pick stuff here that's like
got a really rapid heading versus a
really slow heading but they're actually
end up heading at the 50% point they end
up heading on the same day so this might
be really interesting objectives if you
ever wanted to like pick something
that's early but it actually has a long
duration of heading so we did just some
simple genetic mapping we have we have
GBS on this population about 14,000
markers so we've tested this for days
the heading and for that slope we just
finished simple linear regression here
where we're estimating the effect of
each one of those markers so here's
here's a classic Manhattan plot this is
4 it says up here days - heading so this
is the Association testing for days -
heading here we got two really strong
associations these are actually four
known photo period sensitive alleles
that are segregating in the breeding
material so people do B 1 and D 1 so
those are real nice associations here
there's another Association strong that
found on on one B we haven't quite
figured out what that is and then maybe
another one here on 3 B and then a few
on the unanchored markers but these are
actually turns out that there actually
should be anchored on on to B so overall
you can't really
see it because they line directly up on
top of each other but we did this for
the visual assessments and the neural
network and we can you can see a square
right here in a circle right here so
it's it's cool we can actually now map
genetically map a trait that was fully
scored using the automated imaging and
the neural network so that's the
Manhattan plot this is more of a
Manhattan Kansas plot because it's a
little flatter this is for 5/3 and and
so same thing so even though we had a
nice heritability trait point four we
didn't find much for any genetic
Association on those ones we maybe have
something here onto B but we have to use
genomic prediction models because there
are apparently there's not any major
control of even though it's heritable it
doesn't look like there's any major
major genetic control the rate of
heading okay so this goes back to the
question
all those graduate students were
wondering about it like like you get a
unit distribution like this you got to
say oh there's like some epistasis or
something going on right if you can't
explain it it's epistasis okay so so we
took this we just fit a two-way
interaction model for all the
significant markers so right so it's
marker one by mark or two and then the
interaction of those two markers cool
though if you take this distribution and
you chop it off right here at the
inflection point you run a chi-square of
a three to one on that guy and it fits
it fits really nicely with a three to
one ratio which would be like a two gene
dominance type epistatic model and so
this is a nice working hypothesis we
said ah yeah but there's some nice
epistatic interactions between those two
and so that's what I'm showing here this
is just our first attempt to visualize
this I'm not real sure but here's that
same Association plot you know we had
that strong peak on on to B and 2d for
the for the 2p pd-1 alleles interesting
like here's the allele effect so one of
them was coming from parent one Lincoln
and the other one was coming
to folder right so they so individually
as varieties they hit the right maturity
right but their progeny get like thrown
all over the place okay so so and I
talked with Alan he said yeah for sure
you know we can only have one of these
in the prematurely if you put them both
or too early you have neither one than
they're way too late and sure enough
right we got we got some these are just
the size of these circles or the
significance of interaction so this
there's there's some interaction here
with this this one allele but then
there's really strong at interaction
between the 2b and the 2d allele there
so we have some classic kind of
epistatic interactions this is just the
significance testing of all those
pairwise combinations across the genome
so here's like the classic interaction
plot this because like
this is my favorite plot right directly
out of Falconer I mean yeah
so I'd say here we got like the PPD one
allele and the PPD be one allele right
and then depending on which allele state
you have for each one of these if you
have both of the non sensitive alleles
you're really early around 100 1516 days
if you add one of them you add about two
days if you add the other one you add
about you know four days and then if you
stack them both up the you add in like
14 14 days of the heading die so just
beautiful classic example of these two
alleles interacting and this and just
like I said again this is like our
optimal journey range this is this is
day of the year sorry but this is the
optimal optimal range for Wheaton Kansas
this is pretty early you're risking like
a lot of cold damage and frost damage
and then this is just way too late
you're gonna have a lot of heat stress
in that range so the optimal varieties
are picking one or other of those
alleles even though they're both
floating around the breeding program so
the final thing then is just to say you
know like we drove this with our tractor
you know to give you an honest
assessment of it it takes about so so we
were running through on both populations
which was around like 14
for 1200 1300 field plots and that would
take like a good four to five hours okay
so is it high throughput not really you
can go through visually about the same
amount of time okay but you know doing
this with a UAV is really scalable no
actually and so here I'm just you know
we don't have any good results from this
but this is just to like pretend like we
can do it okay so so this is like using
like a really high resolution camera
from a UAV and actually flying over
these plots using videos so you're
actually taking really high frame rate
and we can we can cover those plots at
two plots per second so we can actually
cover those same thousand pots in about
a 25 minute flight okay so now we've
actually gone high through but okay and
here just to say that it's doable or
theoretically right here again we don't
know if it's doable until we actually
like do the experiment for two years and
get the big data set and stuff but here
like here's an example of images from
there if you zoom in on that middle of
that plot right here you can see these
are headed out these are still moving
before they're headed out so we can
actually get like submillimetre pixel
resolution of these same plots using a
UAV and actually covering them you know
a thousand plots in 20 minutes so this
is like where we're really focused on
now taking the same approach using the
UAV extracted data to see if if we can
we can do this in a truly
high-throughput type of approach okay
so then the real question I'm sure
you've all been wondering now is do we
still need breeders okay so now we've
got genomic selection models that can
predict now which ones are the best
we've got like neural networks that can
actually do the phenotyping to get the
data that goes in to the models so once
the breeders have trained all the neural
networks what do we do here now so we
tested the same thing on a real neural
network ok this network was 2 years and
11 months old at the time of testing we
had one training epoch which was about
two minutes that's all day attention
we had and then we had a sample size of
16 spikes 8 of them were on and 8 were
onlus and then for this project we coded
them as spiky and not spiky meaning like
they were on or on list this was to
simplify you know for the new Lynette
we're encoded I'm a zero and one on
anonymous so here we coded them and
spiky and not spiky so here's my
daughter Talia Marie and let's see if
she can demonstrate this neural network
that's it so the neural network so in
about two minutes you can train a real
neural network to do what took us
several years and 100,000 images so
there's our conclusion so the high
throughput phenotype we're really
getting a production mode I think over
this last year or two years and they
were integrating that into the
prediction modeling where we're building
models that have like a vegetation index
assessment along with the genomic data
and those are actually giving a drastic
input okay I just briefly touched on
that in the beginning the exciting part
is we can measure some complex traits
using deep learning and so in my mind
this is really exciting new frontiers
because theoretically we can extend
those we can extend that model training
it's like any trait that we score right
all that goes into it is a whole bunch
of pictures images that we collected
high throughput in the field and then
whatever the breeder whenever you go out
and visually score right theoretically
can you know we can build a neural
network to score that same trait right
so then it kind of opens up like the
this opportunities so we know the
breeders are still relevant mark at
least for now
and right because somebody's got to like
you know assimilate all this information
and then figure out what to do with it
or at least to ask some graduate
students to do something with it and
then remember everything you need to
know you learned at Cornell while you
were here okay so thanks huge thanks to
Oliver everybody in my group byron
eavers is is our main technician that
manages all the field trials mark Lucas
I mentioned this a few times of graduate
students from March really critical our
group he's a data scientist basically
spends all of his time moving big data
around dodgy it's one of the graduate
students and then Kevin you Wang is
postdoc who was really instrumental on
building the actual phenotype err that
you know took us several years to
collect these datasets and then rich
ground is our new UAV pilot and attina
is another postdoc on the group who's
who's really helped us work through the
high-throughput phenotyping data our
computer science collaborators which
obviously like you know I did a
substantial work on this project is
Robert plusses group at George
Washington and then Hong Lang is a
graduate student on the project and this
was primarily supported through a
National Science Foundation plant genome
research program so it's
I'd be glad to take any questions look
I'm greatly relieved that readers are
still relevant but I how small of a park
and you image can you do it single one
major row we haven't tried single rows
right so the next frontier so these are
these are full-size plots and the trick
is especially with the UAV the trick is
because we're working on this now the
trick is we crop out the outside right
so we don't want like confounding
effects of like the neighboring plot and
so to have sting you know to go down to
single rows or even better like single
plants where you have confounding
effects of like stuff that's like
definitely wrong like something else
overlapping we haven't even tried to
touch that yet so I mean that's like the
real frontier but yeah so we need to do
it on head rows and then we'd really be
high through what's your next trade oh
yeah good question so we've actually on
the same data set we've got barley
yellow Dorf scores which is like sort of
a combination of like yellowing plus
like some anthocyanin purpling so we're
going to we're going to try that really
my next trait is to like do this exact
same thing just using the UAV data yeah
but that the trouble is like there's a
huge amount of pre-processing and like
just to get to the point where we have
like images that can go into the neural
network yeah it's a single color you
play around with different yeah so so
all of our imaging has just been with
like like off-the-shelf RGB cameras like
I didn't I didn't mention but the UAV
for like the vegetation index we fly
like multi spectral cameras the trouble
is the resolution on those cameras is
much much lower so there's really a
balance between I think what goes into
the neural networks the RGB images work
really good and they're more importantly
they're much higher resolution than what
we did from like multi spectral cameras
yeah pictures yeah just give it a date
and give it the images and tell you yeah
so so we're just like that's kind of
like I don't hear again I don't really
understand it but that's kind of like
the frontier of deep learning as far as
what these guys tell me because they're
you're actually putting like two levels
of predictors in right so you have a
structured data set where it's images
but you have to tell the network what
order and what time the images are from
and then give it a classifier right
so the only thing that's going into
these this training set is a bunch of
images and a bunch of classifications
right it can't even think on like you
know a next higher level so but I agree
that with these data sets you can
conceptualize like much smarter ways to
or much more informed ways to train them
that you know taking account the spatial
and temporal relationship and I mean
Mike can attest this - I think right
that our upper limit is like however
good you scored the trait right and so
usually I didn't listen here but like we
can build like digital elevation models
to measure plant height across the whole
breeding nurseries and you can actually
and then we benchmark that against how
you know you go out with the ruler and
measure them you're like oh there's got
to be minimal bias and that but we can
actually hit heritability x' and
accuracies they're better than human
measurements and then we try to
benchmark them against the human
measurement
and so it's like a catch-22 right it's a
well you know our ground truth is not
accurate but we're trying to get more
accurate than our ground truth so but I
think I think though like you know if we
can scale this out to many many many
breeding programs and you know then like
ever you know like multiple scores I
think then you kind of have the you know
the logic of the of the masses kind of
thing where it should even out over a
big enough data set what about you you
change the environment so you have
everything and the Cheney
and also the situation yeah that's good
so I think there's two answers that one
like I think if we do it across the
nephew years and enough different
breeders and programs then you kind of
see all of the variants that are you
know morphological variants that are out
there
the other one is though that there's
opportunities to like actually train
this in season like right so you could
actually take data visually on a small
number of plots and then in season train
these type of things onto like fifty
thousand plots that you don't have the
physical capacity to score and that's
especially the way we're thinking about
it for just the vegetation index right
well build the model will actually
measure yield on like a thousand plots
and then use that information to predict
yield in the same environment to like
fifty thousand
yeah yes this scoring was all done by
Byron right so we just had one score all
right so this is benchmarked across so
we don't really have the confounding
effects of multiple people being biased
oh yeah yeah so the same person there's
there's really minimal internal there's
the internal bias so like like I mean we
had very few time points where it was
like you go out one day and then you go
out the next day and you actually score
it lower than you did the time before
right so we're really not
yeah that's within one person it's
pretty minimal and there's a certain C
in the yeah the same thing again we I
don't know yeah I don't know which one's
wrong I need to go back and probably run
those models again and see which one has
like a better fit on you know like a
smaller error on fitting those maybe but
yeah here again like how do you know
what's right I grew I grew that's much
easier way to like to see which has
higher ability they were the same me for
like heading date now we haven't looked
at that yeah that's a good one yeah
there should be some spec let me know
well we know for sure that there's a
spectral difference between before
they're headed and after they're headed
whether you can actually get like some
percentage that would be a cure enough
to squirt a date
during that progression yeah we don't
know the other trouble is we don't we
don't fly the hyperspectral but like
once a week
no but that's good idea we should try it
there's an error from scoring and
there's an error from you know some plot
set out earlier because they're a little
drier later
so you feed the deviation of the actual
heading from the expected from the
genotype into a at CNN and so they would
try to predict whether okay it's heading
on this date but I think it's probably
early relative to what the genotype like
put some genetic information into there
I'm sure somewhere or get it to try to
predict that other component of error
yeah that was a little biased in the
breeding program yeah within the
breeding program though you don't really
have those major effects still
segregating
right but I mean that's if I'm
understand your question right that's
like along the lines of what we're
thinking on is actually putting would
you be even okay so here's our here's
our sci-fi idea is to actually yeah yeah
yeah so maybe we actually got some fun
new spatial models that actually like
they're like Auto regressive models
except because we've mapped these things
in physical coordinates we apply like an
actual physical correction those
actually perform really well so I would
say maybe that's an easier way than
doing it through the neural net but yeah
I know what you're saying like somehow
feed into the neural network that these
two plots are next to each other versus
these two are like clear across the
field
[Music]
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu